liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz zu unserer
regelmäßigen pressekonferenz zur corona
lage und dazu begrüße ich ganz herzlich
den bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach neben ihm platz genommen auch
schon traditionell professor dr lothar
wieler der präsident des robert koch
instituts und ganz außen sitzen
professor doktor gernot marx er ist der
präsident der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin
als vorbemerkung für alle die uns per
live stream oder live im fernsehen sehen
wie immer die bundespressekonferenz ist
keine institution der bundesregierung
sondern ein unabhängiger verein von
journalistinnen und journalisten die aus
berlin über die bundespolitik richten
wir veranstalten pressekonferenzen dass
unsere mitgliedschaft die leser und
zuhörer und zuschauer besser informieren
kann das als vor bemerken und jetzt
haben sie das wort herr lauterbach
bitteschön ja vielen dank auch
initiativen die das wieder hier in ihrem
haus gast sein dürfen ich war mit der
positiven nachricht an die fallzahlen
gehen deutlich zurück
das ist also eine entwicklung die wir
antizipiert hatten es war daher richtig
die maßnahmen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes noch einmal für
zwei wochen zu verlängern und wir sind
jetzt in einem relativ stabilen rückgang
der fallzahlen gekommen was nicht
richtig gut läuft ist die nachlaufende
zahl der schwererkrankten die noch in
der intensivmedizinischen versorgung
sind und die sterbefälle die daraus
resultieren daher habe ich auch gern
marx gebeten uns heute zu unterstützen
und uns zu berichten wie der sachstand
da genau ist und zu den fallzahlen
selbst rückgang das wird er wieder
gleich machen ich war mir daher zu den
nicht so guten nachrichten dieser woche
und da steht natürlich voll im
vordergrund die niederlage bei der bei
dem versuch der einführung einer
allgemeinen impfpflicht das ist im
deutschen bundestag nicht möglich
gewesen das hat eine klare und auch
bittere niederlage für alle impfpflicht
befürworter gegeben das ist auch für
mich der fahrer natürlich weil ich habe
mich sehr intensiv und aus überzeugung
für die einführung einer allgemeinen
pflicht eingesetzt und das habe ich als
abgeordneter getan nicht in der funktion
des
bundesgesundheitsministers war ja hier
eine ethische frage besprochen haben die
aus der mitte des parlaments zu
entscheiden war aber als abgeordneter er
habe ich mich der ein gesetz auf der
anderen seite ist es auch so dass aus
der perspektive des
gesundheitsministers eine solche alte
mann endlich dringend notwendig gewesen
wäre somit der seine klare
niederlage die in dieser größenordnung
auch also
sehr unwahrscheinlich macht dass sich
hier noch viel im deutschen bundestag
bewegen wird also eine schlechte
nachricht für all diejenigen war damit
anzufangen die sich seit zwei jahren
sollten wir zwei jahren aufopferungsvoll
für schwerstkranke cupid patienten
eingesetzt haben und das weiter tun
das ist aber auch eine schlechte
nachricht für all diejenigen die es von
der erkrankung bedroht sind zum beispiel
diejenigen die auf variablen gruppen
angehören und die eu die impfung nicht
perfekt wirkt oder eine schwache wirkung
nur zeigt die dann immer gefährdet sind
wenn die fallzahlen hoch sind das ist
eine schlechte nachricht für diejenigen
die mit einschränkungen leben müssen
wenn wir beispielsweise
bestimmte
maßnahmen ergreifen müssen die das
normale leben nicht zulassen und es ist
auch an der traurige nachricht für die
also sterbefälle und schwerstkranke die
wir hätten verhindern können durch die
allgemeine impfpflicht
mit diesen leuten habe ich auch nicht
nur mit larsson ich fühle mit ich finde
es ist traurig dass wir über eine so
lange zeit jetzt schon diese hohen die
sterbezahlen pro tag also erleben müssen
und ich hatte gehofft dass wir im herren
in einer anderen lage sein würden das
ist jetzt ungewisser als es gewesen wäre
wenn wir die allgemeine endlich
eingeführt hat der antrag zur
allgemeinen pflicht der hier zum schluss
zur abstimmung stand war ein guter
antrag der hatte meine volle
unterstützung
natürlich wären pflicht ab 18 noch
umfänglicher gewesen aber da über 90
prozent der sterbefälle durch
das gruner virus und mit dem koma virus
bei über 60-jährigen
vorkommen hätte die endlich dieser
besonders wohlhabenden gruppe die im
antrag vorgesehen war als pflichtimpfung
oder als pflicht impfnachweis das hätte
sehr geholfen anders ausgedrückt 90
prozent des medizinischen nutzens den
mann mit einer impfpflicht ab 18
erreicht hätte hätte man auch mit einer
impfpflicht ab 60 erreicht von daher war
ich davon ausgegangen dass diese
moderate kompromiss auch die
unterstützung vieler abgeordneten findet
die sich mit einer endlich ab 18 nicht
einverstanden erklärt hätten aber bei
einer impfpflicht auf die variablen
gruppen und die älteren bezogen durch
aus und das ist aber nicht passiert
was folgt daraus folgt aus im herbst
werden wir wahrscheinlich ein drittes
mal nicht optimal
in die dann zu erwartende welle im
hineingehen es ist natürlich möglich
dass es im herbst keine große welle gibt
dass es möglich aber es ist einfach sehr
unwahrscheinlich ich kann eigentlich
keiner größeren studie und auch keinen
also bekannteren wissenschaftler mit dem
ich in kontakt bin der davon ausgeht
dass wir im herbst nicht eine erneute
welle bekommen was kann eine mikrowelle
sein das kann eine veränderte variante
sei mit der wir ringen müssen das kann
auch eine also die kombinierte variante
sein ist es auf jeden fall mit einer
welle zu rechnen dass es machen sie sich
der dinge wir sehen jetzt schon
anzeichen dafür dass das
virus sich verändert die sogenannte xl
variante es gibt aber auch noch andere
varianten
es gibt die
b1 variante die abgelöst wird durch pa 4
und b a5 ob das unabhängige feiern zum
schluss sein werden oder nicht das
wissen wir nicht aber die
voraussetzungen das neue varianten
entstehen sie dann einfach für das virus
optimal wir haben derzeit hohe
fallzahlen und unterschiedliche
varianten die es schon gibt und die
können sich dann in infizierten re
kombinieren werden jemand mit mehreren
varianten gleichzeitig infiziert ist so
wie es wahrscheinlich auch bei der
entstehung der anderen varianten der
fall gewesen ist somit müssen wir damit
rechnen dass tatsächlich im herbst
entweder omikron oder eine veränderte
omikron variante zu bekämpfen ist und
dann sind wir nicht optimal vorbereitet
was kommt kurzfristig daraus werden wir
weiter gespräche mit der union oder mit
anderen parlamentariern führen ich
glaube man darf sich gesprächen nicht
verweigern
als arzt muss man wenn das leben eines
patienten in gefahr ist immer nichts
unversucht lassen und bis zum schluss
kämpfen und das gilt auch für politiker
die sich mit so einer solchen materials
schloss letztlich um das leben von
menschen geht die wir schützen wollen
handelt ich bin aber sehr skeptisch weil
wir haben ja gesprächsangebote über
viele monate gemacht und dabei ist
nichts herausgekommen
ich habe ja auch gestern in meiner rede
die union direkt angesprochen und
gebeten dass sie uns staatstragend
unterstützt in der situation in der wir
jetzt waren das ist nicht passiert von
daher bin ich sehr skeptisch und glauben
offen gesagt nicht dass wir durch
zusätzliche gespräche noch etwas
erreichen können es ist hier nicht die
zeit von schuldzuweisungen ich werde
mich daher an schuldzuweisungen auch
nicht also beteiligen das verfahren
hat aber ein klares ergebnis gehabt und
mit diesem ergebnis müssen wir leben
was folgt daraus mittelfristig
mittelfristig erfolg daraus also drei
jahre zum einen wir haben keinen
spielraum mehr für weitere lockerungen
die lockerungen können jetzt nicht
fortgesetzt werden wir haben das was wir
an lockerungen machen konnten haben wir
verbraucht wir haben nach wie vor die
rote zahlen wir haben 200 bis 300 tote
pro tag die zahl der menschen die
sterben stark derzeit sogar noch an im
herbst müssten wir erwarten dass die
lage sich nicht also verbessert sondern
verschlechtert wie werden auch eine
sommer welle wahrscheinlich haben das
stimmigste einschätzung von den posten
zu womit der spielraum für lockerungen
ist komplett aufgebraucht in dem
zusammenhang ist es auch richtig dass
wir die zuerst diskutierte also
veränderungen der isolations und
garantieren eine verordnung die darauf
hinausgelaufen wäre dass die isolation
von kona infizierten durch die
gesundheitsämter nicht mehr angeordnet
wird dass wir das nicht machen das habe
ich ja selbst zurückgenommen wir haben
das diskutiert was wäre ab dem ersten
mal möglicherweise in kraft getreten
aber das können wir uns einfach nicht
leisten
wir hätten damit das völlig falsche
signal gegeben als bewohner infektionen
eine isolation nicht benötigt und die
gesundheitsämter das nicht machen wir
nicht mehr machen müssen der vorschlag
ist zurückgenommen und er wird auch
jetzt nicht mehr verfolgt auf absehbare
zeit es war auch richtig dass wir das
infektionsschutzgesetz um zwei wochen
verlängert haben und die hotspot
regelung gemacht haben aber damit werden
wir mit sicherheit im herbst nicht über
die runden kommen das heißt wir müssen
uns jetzt auch schon darauf einstellen
dass wir spätestens am 23 09 dann läuft
das infektionsschutzgesetz heraus was
wir jetzt haben vielleicht früher je
nachdem wie die entwicklung sich also
abzeichnet müssen wir noch einmal an das
infektionsschutzgesetz sicherlich heran
denn wir können
mit dem was
nicht ohne eine masken pflicht zum
beispiel in den herbst hinein gehen
werden wir keine also allgemeine
nebenpflicht erreichen gehen mit der
fluke in den herbst hinein und haben
darüber hinaus diese alte bevölkerung
die wir zu schützen haben wir haben
hohen altersdurchschnitt in deutschland
und bis dahin haben auch die booster
impfungen und die zweite impfung und ein
stück weit ihre wirkung verloren müssen
wir auf jeden fall noch einmal an das
infektionsschutzgesetz haben damit
erkläre ich keine neuigkeiten das ist ja
so ohnedies vorgesehen dass wir im
september nachdem also spätestens zum 23
09 das gesetz noch einmal aufmachen
müssen und ich glaube dass wir uns
einfach mehr freiheiten im
infektionsschutzgesetz hätten leisten
können wenn wir hier zu einer
allgemeinen endlich gekommen werden und
hätten die große im fluge die es bei
älteren in dieser form jahr in anderen
europäischen ländern nicht gibt die
anderen europäischen länder haben wir
westeuropäischen der namen der zu einem
großen teil eine viel geringere zahl von
älteren menschen über 60 die nicht
geimpft sind also wenn da wir diese
lücke haben müssen wir auch beim
infektionsschutzgesetz vorsichtig sein
und schließlich wir müssen noch einmal
an eine kreative kampagne für die
impfung herangehen wir haben das schon
also einiges gemacht wir haben auch also
subgruppen und so satin spezifische
kampagne gemacht ist in der
öffentlichkeit zum teil nicht so viel
gesehen worden weil die eben in den
entsprechenden community stattfinden
aber da müssen wir noch einmal einen
kreativen aufschlag machen wir müssen
die zeit nutzen über die nächsten monate
tatsächlich kontinuierlich für die
impfung zu werben wenn wir das kreativ
und gut machen also wirklich kreative
werbung im verbund die auch gut erklärt
und gründe gibt sich impfen zu lassen
das läuft für einige monate glaube ich
wird das auch für den herbst an der
unterschied machen lassen sie mich
abschließend noch etwas zudem fürchte in
den osterferien sagen ich bitte alle die
die reise für ostern jetzt planen sich
vor der reise noch testen zu lassen so
dass wir während der reise und auch bei
den besuchen die dann geplant sind
andere nicht anstecken und auch ein
geringes risiko über ostern haben dass
andere uns anstecken die osterreise darf
hier nicht also zu einem zu einer
unterbrechung der derzeit günstigen
entwicklung der fallzahlen führen das
sollten wir tun für alle die mit uns
reisen das sollten wir aber auch tun zum
schutz unserer familien zum eigenen
schutz und
schließlich will ich auch noch mal
daraufhin lassen die stiko hat die
filter dosis für alle ab 70 empfohlen
und für diejenigen die risikofaktoren
wie zum beispiel immundefekte oder ein
geschenk das immunsystem haben zum
beispiel auf der grundlage von
krebserkrankungen die baden und werden
müssen die fürther dosis wird viel zu
wenig genutzt viel zu wenig genutzt
werden dort nicht die nutzung die wir
brauchen derzeit sind die impfzentren
gut in der lage termine zu vergeben ich
empfehle daher allen jetzt umgehend die
voerder dosis in anspruch zu nehmen die
durch die empfehlung der stiko abgedeckt
werden ich rate auch zu einer
großzügigen
interpretation der empfehlung der stiko
wir sind hier nicht nur diejenigen die
immundefekt haben die studienlage aus
israel ist relativ eindeutig dass also
die sterblichkeit für diejenigen die die
vierte impfung vier monate nach der
dritten nehmen und die über 60 sind
sterblichkeit geht noch einmal um etwa
etwas weniger als 80 prozent zurück
selbst wenn man die methodischen
schwächen dieser studie mit einberechnet
entsprechen wir hier von anna serie
nennenswerten senkung der sterblichkeit
daher appelliere ich dafür dass man die
empfehlung der stiko liberal
interpretiert und dass diejenigen sich
mit der vierten folgendes ausstatten die
also risikofaktoren haben zum beispiel
herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen oder
diabetes
hypertonie patienten herzinsuffizienz
patienten menschen die chronisch
obstruktive lungenerkrankungen haben
rheumatischer patienten die also
methotrexat oder andere immunsuppressiva
geben müssen die liste ist lang hermanns
kann das so vielleicht nur ausführen die
vierte impfung steht zur verfügung und
ist für die über 60 jährigen die
risikofaktoren haben auch noch mal ein
also wichtiger schutz wir blicken nach
vorn das war eine schlechte woche für
den schutz der bevölkerung vor der
korona infektionen aber wir geben
erstens nicht auf wir machen weiter und
wir müssen auch zurückblicken bisher ist
es auch nicht immer schlecht gelaufen
wenn man die sterblichkeit also in
deutschland gemessen die alte unserer
bevölkerung ist und wie hoch die
impfquote soll genauer gesagt die quote
der nicht geimpft wenn man das
heranzieht dann haben wir immer noch
eine deutlich bessere sterblichkeit als
die meisten unserer nachbarländer und
unsere arbeit muss darauf hinauslaufen
dass wir dies erhalten lasse dies weiter
schaffen dass wir weiter einen
konservativen kurs fahren deutschland
hat einen konservativen kurs
durchgezogen zum schutze der bevölkerung
daran werden wir festhalten auch wenn in
dieser woche die allgemeine impfpflicht
nicht so wie geplant beschlossen werden
konnte herzlichen dank alter war herr
professor wieder ja wir haben gegen
hörfunk der aktuellen welle
überschritten die fallzahlen sinken und
das in allen bundesländern sinken die
sieben tage ins tänzen und allen
altersgruppen
beobachten wir eine absenkung der sieben
tages instanzen und zwar deutlich das
sind sehr gute nachrichten für uns alle
trotz des deutlichen rückgangs sind die
fallzahlen und sieben tage instanzen
aber immer noch auf einem hohen niveau
es gibt immer noch landkreise die haben
eine sieben tage ins ident über 3000 und
durch die hohen fallzahlen sind
natürlich auch nach wie vor viele
menschen krank in isolation oder
quarantäne
wahrscheinlich kennt jeder von uns
jemanden der jetzt gerade kurve hat oder
erst kürzlich cupid hatte in den meisten
fällen läuft die infektion mild und das
ist natürlich tatsächlich sehr
beruhigend
dennoch bleibt bedrückend dass immer
noch täglich zwei bis dreihundert
todesfälle in verbindung mit coop 19 an
das robert koch institut übermittelt
werden auch bei einer positiven lage
entwicklung werden wir wahrscheinlich
noch länger diese hohen todesfall zahlen
sehen denn in der regel
verstärke die mit menschen die an cupid
19 infizieren wurden etwa zwei bis drei
wochen nach der infektion
in der aktuellen lage sind auch nach wie
vor die strukturen des gesundheitswesens
sehr groß belastet
das heißt also das sind die pflege die
ambulanten versorgung die stationären
versorger und natürlich auch immer noch
die labor- und gesundheitsämter
seit vielen jahren informiert die
syndrome janes des robert-koch-instituts
erreger unabhängig über die aktuelle
krankheit schwere und häufigkeit der
akuten atemwegsinfektion in unserem land
diese daten werden von der bevölkerung
von arztpraxen und von krankenhäusern
direkt an das robert koch institut
übermittelt
die systeme wurden nach den empfehlungen
der vero extra auch für eine pandemie
bewältigung entwickelt und sie haben
sich bereits seit jahren in der
influenza vereins bewährt sie geben uns
deshalb ein gutes bild über die akuten
atemwegserkrankungen in unserer
bundesdeutschen bevölkerung
wir beobachten dass in der aktuellen
welle die zahl der schweren
krankheitsverläufe bei gleichzeitig
hohen infektionszahlen deutlich
niedriger ist die rate der
atemwegsinfektionen bei kindern und
erwachsenen ist im vergleich zur
vorwoche gesunken und liegt im bereich
der werte von den pandemischen von den
vier pandemischen jahre die anzahl der
arztbesuche ist ebenfalls gesunken und
die anzahl der schweren
atemwegsinfektion mit kurven 19 diagnose
im krankenhaus geht kontinuierlich
zurück
und bei der zahl der wöchentlichen
neuaufnahmen schwere atemwegsinfektion
auf die intensivstation haben wir fast
schon das niedrige niveau erreicht das
wir vor der pandemie im sommer gesehen
haben das sind sehr gute entwicklungen
wir haben von beginn der pandemie
bekämpfung an konsequent eine strategie
gefahren in unserem land diese strategie
besteht aus drei säulen der eindämmung
von infektionen dem schutz der
wohngruppen und der sogenannten
abmilderung durch behandlung der
patienten in unserem gesundheitssystem
diese drei säulen greifen kontinuierlich
ineinander omikron ist ansteckender als
alle früheren varianten
das hat zu fall zahlen geführt die wir
in den früheren wählen so nicht gesehen
hatten durch die extrem hohen fallzahlen
ist die verhinderung jeder übertragung
nicht immer möglich um infektionsketten
zu brechen das ist auch nicht mehr immer
um jeden preis nötig es gelingt nicht
mehr jeden einzelnen fall
nachzuverfolgen der fokus unserer
strategie verschiebt sich also zunehmend
auf den schutz der wunde radeln gruppen
sowie die abmilderung
der folgen der erkrankung die
kombination von einem steigenden
immunschutz in der bevölkerung und zwar
durch gut wirksame impfungen oder den
direkten kontakt mit dem virus sowie ein
grundsätzlich geringeren anteil schwerer
erkrankungen bei infektionen durch die
omikron variante führt insgesamt zu
einem geringeren anteil schwerer cupid
19 infektionen
ein problem ist aber
die vielen personen die nur mit der
nikon variante infiziert waren aber eben
nicht geimpft sind die haben nach allem
was wir heute wissen keinen guten schutz
gegen die anderen varianten
wir wissen seit vielen monaten wie wir
uns vor kuwait 19 schützen können wir
haben in diesem werkzeugkasten der sich
im laufe der zeit immer weiter
entwickelt hat das schritt für schritt
angepasst an das wissen dass wir über
das virus erlangt haben wir hatten dank
genialer und tüchtiger wissenschaftler
das glück das uns eine wirksame impfung
so früh zur verfügung stand denn wir
wissen
die impfung kann nicht immer vor
infektionen vor ansteckung schützen
wenn aber viele menschen geimpft
interesse reduziert sich auch das eigene
infektionsrisiko und wenn wir uns
trotzdem vom angesteckt haben reduziert
die impfung das risiko erstens für einen
schweren cupid 19 verlauf zweitens für
einen tödlichen cupid 19 verlauf und
drittens nach den neuesten
untersuchungen auch vor den
langzeitfolgen die wir als longo wird
kennen alle garten belegen dass eine
grundimmunisierung insbesondere die
auffrischimpfung einen sehr hohen schutz
vor schwersten verläufen auch mit nikon
bietet
und in diesem zusammenhang ist es auch
wirklich wichtig zu verstehen und zu
wissen auch wenn sie bereits einmal
infiziert waren lassen sie sich trotzdem
impfen so können sie den bestmöglichen
schutz erreichen
ich fasse zusammen wir sind in einer
deutlich besseren lage als zu beginn der
pandemie
wir haben mit einer kurve 19 variante zu
tun die beide kämpften meist nur eine
meldung erkrankungen hervorruft und uns
stehen sehr wirksame impfstoffe zur
verfügung
lassen sie sich also impfen und wenn es
noch nicht getan haben lassen sich
auffrischen denn die booster impfung ist
wirksamer als zwei impfdosen bei der
immunschutz nach der grundimmunisierung
nachlässt ist die auffrischimpfung jetzt
besonders wichtigen
halten sie sich an die empfehlungen der
stiko die stiko ist eine
wissenschaftlich unabhängiges gremium
das evidenzbasierte empfehlungen
ausspricht
für manche honorable gruppen minister
lauterbach hat es gerade nochmals betont
wird eine zweite auffrischimpfung von
der stiko empfohlen wenn sie diese
auffrischimpfung noch nicht haben bitte
holen sie sie nach
und auch wenn sie eine kurve 19
infektion hatten aber bisher nie geimpft
waren lassen sie sich impfen sie haben
dann einen ausgezeichneten immunschutz
und haben sie bitte weiterhin
eigenverantwortlich auch masken
insbesondere in innenräumen mit anderen
personen und wenn sie symptome haben
bleiben sie bitte möglichst zu hause und
treffen sie eben nicht die wohlhabenden
in unserer gesellschaft
höheres risiko haben diese
wollen mit menschen in unserer
gesellschaft
sie brauchen unsere solidarität und
unsere rücksicht bitte lassen wir sie
ihnen auch zu kommen wir erwarten einen
sommer mit dem vergleich zum letzten
sommer hohen fallzahlen wir müssen daher
alle weiterhin vorsichtig mit dieser
situation umgehen und am ende meine
damen und herren geht es ja um
menschenleben lassen sie uns gemeinsam
füreinander sorgen und positiv nach
vorne blicken wir haben alle werkzeuge
in der hand um das geschehen zu
kontrollieren
dankeschön professor wille dann
professor markus bitteschön vielen dank
weil ich dies in aller regel immer
gefragt die gute nachricht zuerst
bundesweit gibt es nach den
informationen der die league eine
überlastung der intensivstation trotz
weiterhin hoher inzidenz
unsere situation in der intensiv und
notfallmedizin mit blick auf die
versorgung und behandlung von patienten
ist derzeit beherrsche war seit anfang
februar liegt die anzahl der kurve
patienten auf intensivstationen konstant
zwischen 2000 und 2400 patienten aktuell
gut
2020 und nicht mehr wie zum beispiel im
dezember bei 5.000 patienten durch die
in der regel milderen verläuft von
omikron müssen wir anteilsmäßig deutlich
weniger koma patienten auf den
intensivstationen
behandeln wir behandeln auch kürzer in
der regel bei omikron neun tage das war
zum beispiel der data variante noch
doppelt so lange wird 18 tagen im mittel
wir waren sehr viele ältere menschen
wieder knapp 80 prozent aller patienten
behandeln sind 60 und älter
jetzt die schlechte nachricht auch wenn
ich sage wir verzeichnen keine
überlastung der intensivstation durch
kurve patienten so sind die stationen
doch wieder mehr als belastet hier
machen sich die hohen instanzen durchaus
bemerkbar seit mitte februar stehen
wieder immer mehr ampeln unserer
intensivstation auf rot derzeit knapp 40
prozent das heißt
525 von 1324 stationen in deutschland
das bedeutet eingeschränkter betrieb
hier müssen wieder ubs verschoben werden
sind intensivbetten für die versorgung
von notfallpatienten mehr als knapp und
arbeitet das personal weiter in der
milliyet der grund im moment ist vor
allen dingen fehlendes und dieses mal
vor allen dingen erkranktes personal 100
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter sind
positiv viele sind krank und damit nicht
arbeitsfähig die hohe quote fehlender
mitarbeiter ist für das
gesundheitssystem insgesamt und im
besonderen auf den intensivstationen
belassen eine wirklich große
herausforderung im moment
es ist daher unerlässlich
perspektivisch zu planen und zu handeln
ja früher und sommer werden vielleicht
nicht die entlastungen bringen sie den
letzten zwei jahren aber es wird eine
entlastung geben wenn die in flerke
allerdings weiterhin bei rund 25 prozent
liegt zu erwarten wir im herbst wieder
stark steigende patientenzahlen
insbesondere auf der intensivstation
corona ist noch nicht vorbei wir müssen
weiter wachsam bleiben
dazu werden auch viele patienten mit
anderen infektionserkrankungen
medizinische hilfen der klinik und auch
auf den intensivstationen benötigen ich
denke jetzt zum beispiel an die
influenza grippe wellen haben wir in den
letzten beiden wintern durch die hygiene
abstandsregeln und das konsequente
tragen von masken kaum gesehen wir
befürchten sie werden nächsten winter
kommen entsprechend schon heute unser
hotel weiter an die hygienemaßnahmen
denken zu mit dem maske tragen weiter
voran gehen und denken sie im frühherbst
auch an die grippeimpfung
was braucht es also derzeit aus sicht
der intensiv und notfallmedizin
vorbereitung die infektionszahlen werden
weiter sinken wenn wir weiterhin klug
und umsichtig handeln wie eben auch
schon ausgeführt und bereits sind
gelernte anzuwenden wenn wir die
regionalen entwicklungen und hier haben
wir sehr hohe unterschiede tatsächlich
im moment frühzeitig erkennen müssen wir
bereit sein gegenzusteuern
nach jedem einsatz stellen wir als
notfallmediziner für den nächsten
unseren koffer mit medikamenten
verbandsmaterial equipment wieder so
zusammen dass er komplett ist und
einsatzbereit wenn der nächste notruf
kommt wir erwarten einen solchen koffer
mit politischen das instrumenten für
herbst und winter damit im zweifel alles
was geht zum einsatz kommen kann und
zwar sofort
wir haben in der intensivmedizin in den
chorälen unter hochdruck strukturen
geschaffen die es jetzt gehen dauerhaft
zu etablieren so sind viele berufstätige
wie sie auch haben wir lernt wird per
video konferenz im team
zusammenzuarbeiten haben die
telemedizinische netzwerk in der
intensivmedizin und notfallmedizin
etabliert patient in kleineren häusern
konnten von der expertise größerer
profitieren unzählige transporte konnten
zusätzliche eingespart werden viele
weitere solcher innovativen maßnahmen
wurden im eiltempo geschaffen wir
fordern dass diese zum beispiel die
telemedizin für intensiv und notfalls
auch ins portfolio regelversorgung
aufgenommen werden und nicht nur für
kroner patienten sondern für alle schwer
kranken patienten diese maßnahmen sind
unserer meinung nach ein wichtiges
rüstzeug für die zukunftsvorsorge in
unserem land und last but not least das
personal die wichtigste vorbereitung für
die die wichtigste ressource im
gesundheitswesen sind die menschen die
hier arbeiten
sie brauchen perspektiven entlastung
psychosoziale unterstützung es gibt ja
sehr viele batterien auf den titel in
den teams die wieder aufzuladen sind
hier braucht es also wirklich ein
wirklich großes maßnahmenpaket und eine
langfristige perspektive um alle weiter
in dem job zu halten und vielleicht
sogar neue menschen die wir für diese
arbeit begeistern also perspektivisch
wir brauchen diese politischen einsatz
koffer wir brauchen die etablierung
neuer strukturen und wir brauchen mehr
denn je jeden einzelnen mitarbeitenden
im gesundheitswesen vielen dank
herzlichen dank professor marx dann
kommen wir zu fragen ich unternehmer mal
den versuch einer sortierung völlig auch
online sehr viele fragen zum thema
impfpflicht habe würde ich damit gerne
anfangen und ich beginne auch mit einem
mit einer online fragen von der bild
fragt an sie herr lauterbach ist die
ablehnung des bundestags bei der
impfpflicht eine wird zitiert herbe
niederlage nachdem kein anderes
europäisches land eine impfpflicht hat
beziehungsweise diese umsetzt oder
sprechen sie von einer niederlage für
sich selbst und welche konsequenzen
ziehen sie aus
seine
niederlage für all diejenigen die also
die allgemeine impfnachweis nicht
durchsetzen wollten und also dazu zähle
auch ich habe sehr intensiv für diese
impfpflicht geworben das habe ich aber
nicht zum selbstzweck gemacht sondern
weil ich einfach die situation schon
jetzt unbefriedigend finde wir haben im
moment wir beklagen
200 bis 300 todesfälle die
intensivmedizinische situation hat sich
entspannt
marx hat das ausgeführt dann sterben
auch viele menschen die gar nicht mehr
auf die intensivstation kommen und somit
also ist das keine situation an die ich
mich einfach gewöhnen möchte dass wir
einfach jetzt für die nächste zeit sagen
also wir verlieren jeden tag 300 leute
oder 200 leute an kurven oder erst recht
im herbst und jetzt käme ja quasi erst
mal der sommer romy damit rechnen können
dass die sterbezahlen heruntergehen im
herbst hätten wir eine solche
perspektive nicht werden wir jetzt im
oktober und hätten die fallzahlen die
wir heute vielleicht noch wieder eine
ansteckende variante
und würden dann auch wieder 200 oder 300
menschen verlieren pro tag hätten aber
keine perspektive dass das ändert über
die nächsten monate das ist einfach
etwas was ich uns allen ersparen möchte
und die daher ist für mich da nicht
maßgeblich das ende andere länder tun
daran orientieren wir uns mal mehr mal
weniger aber wir sollten uns überlegen
was ist eigentlich richtig für unsere
bevölkerung jetzt schon darauf
hingewiesen dass wir eine relativ gute
bilanz haben in bezug auf die zahl der
menschen die gestorben sind immer noch
viel zu viele aber diese bilanz so und
auch diese erfolge möchte ich einfach
fortsetzen und damit sind wir auch schon
bald frage was bedeutet das für mich das
bedeutet für mich dass ich in umso
intensiver mich dafür einsetzen muss das
mit allen zur verfügung stehenden
mitteln die bevölkerung hier geschützt
bleibt
dann eher jungen bitte ja auch noch mal
zu impfpflicht oder debatte gestern der
lauterbacher wieder da vielen gästen
auch in den wortbeiträgen setzen wie
sieht ihre impfungen dienen dem
selbstschutz und nicht dem fremdschutz
so etwas kommt nicht aus der afg sondern
zb von ihrem koalitionspartner
lauterbacher also herr kubicki hat das
gesagt wie kann das nach zwei ein
pandemie war noch sein dass so ein
unsinn gesagt wird und warum klären sie
ihre eigenen koalitionspartner nicht
aufgebaut und daher wieder was denken
sie bei solchen sätzen ja zunächst also
ich habe ja ein kubicki meiner rede
direkt angesprochen und ich hätte an
kubicki sehr aber seine expertise in
puncto also
im wirkungen impfschutz sind noch immer
nicht da wo sie sein müssten nach dieser
langen zeit das ist aber also es hat
jetzt nichts mit also der ampel
regierung statur und das ist ja quasi
kann regierungshandeln sondern vertritt
hat diese position ist da nicht optimal
informieren ich habe ja selbst in meiner
rede angeboten dass ich entsprechend der
literatur ihnen zur verfügung stelle
das kann ich nicht viel mehr zu ergänzen
die die faktenlage ist wie sie ist und
bestellen halt immer wieder fest dass es
menschen gibt die fakten negieren
buschow von camille marceau pardon
nachfrage gerade wer regiert eigentlich
jetzt nach einer politik
der regierung wert da sagen wir regieren
als also koalition aus anderen koalition
und ich glaube dass das also das ist ja
eine also
die frage sei ja im prinzip antworten
aus wenn in der korona politik die fdp
also die
regierungspolitik bestimmen würde das
ist definitiv und klar nicht so also wir
agieren also im verbund und dazu also
zählen die dinge die da zu beschließen
waren aber eben nicht die allgemeinen
pflicht die impfpflicht ist eine
entscheidung des deutschen bundestags
gewesen dass kein regierungsentscheidung
gewesen anders ausgedrückt also gestern
hat also die bundesregierung keine
niederlage genommen auch nicht olaf
scholz sondern es war eine entscheidung
aus dem deutschen bundestag zu
überlassen und der deutsche bundestag
hat das zwar nicht so wie ich es mir
gewünscht hätte aber doch autonom
entschieden dass ergebnisse sehr klar
gewesen ob
spd fragt sie professor willi wie
enttäuscht
sie das scheitern der pflicht so heißt
die frage also die impfpflicht ist ja
eine politische entscheidung
und insofern kommentiere ich das nicht
aber
die frage ist wie bekommen wir die
menschen geimpft im herbst oder vor dem
herbst rechtzeitig und
ich gehe davon aus dass der anteil der
menschen die in den herbst geimpft
gegangen wären bei einer impfpflicht
größer gewesen wäre als ohne eine
impfpflicht aber mein ziel ist es und
alle diejenigen die wirklich denen die
gesundheit der menschen am herzen liegt
ist das eben mehr menschen geimpft
werden wir müssen und sich impfen lassen
und das ist sehr sehr anstrengend denn
offensichtlich muss man dort sehr genau
in die einzelnen gruppen reinigen und
mit sogenannten peers dann sehr sehr
viel überzeugungsarbeit leisten wenn die
umfragen sieht die kosten umfang und
andere dann hat man nicht das gefühl
dass da noch sehr viel luft nach oben
ist aber natürlich müssen wir das weiter
versuchen die impfung schützt eben in
erster linie vor schweren
krankheitsverläufen und vor dem tod sie
schützt nicht so gut vor der infektion
aber eben vor den schweren
krankheitsverläufen tod und das ist
einfach einfach immer vermitteln müssen
da werden wir weiter daran arbeiten
vielen dank laut weiß noch nicht ganz
verstanden habe wird es denn
möglicherweise oder sehen sie noch die
möglichkeit für einen zweiten wie auch
immer gearteten anlauf bei einer
impfpflicht wenn ich sie gestern kurz
nachdem die endlich den bundestag
gescheitert ist richtig verstanden hat
haben sie sich ein stück weit dafür
ausgesprochen danach im kanzleramt bei
herrn scholz und der sagte die
demokratie hat gesprochen jetzt müssen
alle anderen mittel ins feld geführt
werden was auch immer das bedeutet
insofern sehen sie dann noch eine
möglichkeit und wenn ja welche und an
herrn marx würde ich ganz gern im
prinzip dieselbe griff frage gestellt
ist es denn medizinisch eigentlich
notwendig weil alles was wir heute hier
vorgetragen haben schreit nach einer
impfpflicht weiterhelfen würde
ja ich habe gestern in meiner rede ich
schon gesagt dass der tag gestern war
dass die parteien die sich entschieden
haben das zu einer parteipolitischen
fragen zu machen das waren ja im
wesentlichen zwei stück
wie von mir wie folgt also angesprochen
werden von der eigenen partei erwarte
ich nicht so von der anderen hätte ich
mir gestern und staatstragende
solidarische hilfe erhofft deshalb
steuer in meiner rede auch öffentlich
gemacht weil das also ist nicht gut dass
man also so etwas hinter den kulissen
oder in hintergrundgesprächen weil ich
habe es offen angesprochen ich bin daher
sehr pessimistisch dass es zu solchen
gesprächen in dem sinne kommen wird dass
sie etwas bringt muss ich einfach
einräumen denn also gestern wir die
gelegenheit gewesen und wir haben ja
über monate hinweg verhandelt dort soll
ist es so also gehe ich auch gestern
mitgeteilt habe man kann sich solchen
gesprächen nicht verschließen
man muss einfach alles versuchen einfach
nichts unversucht lassen aber ich bin da
sehr pessimistisch weil die ergebnisse
waren gestern klar und es kann gut sein
dass hier gesprächsangeboten uhr also
gemacht werden
um von einer harten ablehnung der
impfpflicht abzulenken das kann ich aber
nicht gut sagen daher keine
schuldzuweisungen keine allgemeine ich
sagen mal
ablehnung von gesprächen aber eine
realistische und das bedeutet sehr
pessimistische einschätzung ich glaube
wir werden in den nächsten wochen dazu
kann wirklich ergebnis reichen
gesprächen kommen
die db hat sich bereits im november
letzten jahres klar positioniert für
eine allgemeine impfpflicht auf 18 warum
weil wir verhindern wollten dass unnötig
zusätzliche schwere erkrankungen leid
tod und lankowitz in einem ausmaß
stattfindet was man durch eine
allgemeine impfpflicht deutlich
reduzieren hätte können
zusätzlich sind wir das sicher dass wir
durch eine allgemeine impfpflicht den
herbst und winter deutlich in einer
anderen situation zu finden hätten als
wir worauf wir jetzt wahrscheinlich
hinaus steuern allerdings muss man jetzt
einfach sagen in dem das gesetz gestern
abschlägig beschieden worden ist
bundestag das muss man akzeptieren aber
deswegen ist ins jahr nicht weniger
wichtig geworden ich glaube wir müssen
umso mehr jetzt auch wenn jetzt wie
umfragen so darauf andeuten dass es
immer schwieriger wird dürfen wir nicht
aufhören alles dafür zu tun dass sich
möglichst viele menschen impfen lassen
die noch nicht geimpft sind respektive
sich boostern lassen oder die vierte
impfung erhalten damit wir eben
insbesondere eben also ich muss auch
sagen diese anzahl von 2 bis 300 toten
jeden tag die finde ich als arzt mal
persönlich gesprochen auch einfach nicht
erträglich das ist etwas was hier nicht
so hinnehmen können und welche menschen
sterben es sind insbesondere die eltern
die um hilfen und diejenigen mit
vorerkrankungen und die gilt es einfach
insbesondere zu schützen und dafür
müssen wir alles tun mit impfzentren
kampagnen wie der minister gesagt hat
und eben ständiger überzeugungsarbeit
das ist einfach unsere aufgabe
wenn ich noch eine nachfrage stellen
werden ja eben schon auch durch die
frageform kollegen jungen angerissen
inwiefern die gescheiterte im pflicht
jetzt eine auf dem scheitern oder
scheitern der ampel eigentlich ist ich
würde viel mehr interessieren herr
scholz hat am anfang der führung
bestellt der bekommt sie auch unsere den
eindruck dass das die führung ist die
wir brauchen jetzt im hinblick auf
herbst und winter
ist die frage mich wer immer sich gerne
berufen fühlt ich weiß dass es für sie
vielleicht leichter ist zu beantworten
als für den minister das ist eigentlich
eine frage die ich als intensiv und
notfallmedizin nicht beantworten kann
und auch das ist das ist nicht unsere
aufgabe so zu sagen
hat ich mag konzernbereichen irgendeiner
kollege
redet hier oder telefoniert oder spricht
das ist total störend ob sie das bitte
wenden könnten danke
dann vielleicht die frage eben an herrn
lauterbach
ist eine führung notwendig man hätte
sich vorstellen können andere hätten
reicht eine richtlinienkompetenz gezogen
wenn es auch schwierig ist
die ansonsten habe ich ja eben schon
gegeben habe ich möchte das noch mal
wiederholen wir haben uns als
bundesregierung sehr früh entschieden
dass die frage ob eine allgemeine
impfpflicht kommt oder nicht einer
gewissensentscheidung des solchen
bundestag sein soll und das war aus
meiner sicht eine entscheidung zu der
man dann später stehen muss das ergebnis
ist nicht das was ich mir gewünscht
hätte aber es war eine gut
nachvollziehbare also entscheidung wie
er gestern in der debatte gehört haben
es ging um grundrechte es ging um die
unversehrtheit es ging also um unser
allgemeines staatsverständnis was darf
der status darf er nicht wir sind die
einzelnen rechte gegeneinander
aufzurechnen von daher ist es eine
klassische debatte die man also aus
gewissensentscheidung führen kann man
muss sie nicht zu führen man kann sie
sofern das war eine klare entscheidung
die habe ich auch immer mitgetragen und
dann muss man auch mit dem ergebnis
leben und wenn das das verfahren ist
dann ist auch keine führung also
sinnvoll dass ich habe mich daher ja
auch nicht klar gesundheitsminister
eingemischt in die debatte sondern als
abgeordneter und habe daher bei der
debatte auch ganz gezielt unter den
abgeordneten gestern platz genommen weil
ich habe gestern quasi als abgeordnete
für diese allgemeine nebenpflicht
geworben
auch noch eine frage an sie professor
lauterbach gibt es teile des impfpflicht
vorschlags die sie nun trotzdem
gesetzgeberisch aufgreifen würden
beispielsweise eine beratungspflicht
fragt sascha meyer von tph ja eine
beratungspflicht macht ja nur dann sinn
wenn ich weiß wofür ich berate das
müsste dann ja einer impfpflicht sei
eine beratungspflicht für eine
impfpflicht die es dann nicht gibt kann
nicht wirklich sinnvoll sein
und dann habe ich noch eine frage zum
thema impfpflicht es gibt aber auch noch
an fragen jan drebes von rheinischen
post fragt auch an sie herr lauterbach
wie enttäuscht sind sie vom
koalitionspartner fdp dass ihre krone
dass ihr corona management durch das
verhalten der liberalen immer wieder
torpediert wird
warum sehen sie heute anders als gestern
doch keine chance mehr für einen neuen
anlauf der impfpflicht ich glaube dazu
haben sie schon genug gesagt aber die
erste frage also die
dass die ampel parteien bei der krone
politik zum teil nicht in jedem punkt
die gleiche position vertreten das ist
ja bekannt und gehört auch zu einer also
koalition dazu politik ist kompromiss
und wenn drei parteien also regieren
dann ist es ganz klar dass diesen
unterschiedlichen schwerpunkten auch
rechnung getragen werden muss trotzdem
ist es insgesamt so dass wir fair
miteinander umgehen und bisher aus
meiner sicht auch ganz gut gefahren sind
haben zum beispiel durch diese sehr
schneller poster kampagne aus die
del-tabelle ja viel tödlicher verlief
also
stattgefunden hat haben wir uns sehr
schnell gemeinsam auf eine poster
kampagne also
verständigt die auch gut geklappt hat
das wird oft also nicht so wahrgenommen
was funktioniert und was nicht
funktioniert steht im vordergrund
aber wir haben tatsächlich also gemessen
an den ländern mit denen wir uns sonst
vergleichen haben wir bei der dritten
impfung in sehr kurzer zeit mehr
erreicht als das was wir bei der zweiten
impfung in sehr langer zeit davor
erreicht hatten da sind unsere quoten
nicht so schlecht das hat dazu geführt
dass die sterblichkeit zurückgegangen
sein erfolg und ich glaube dass auch das
infektionsschutzgesetz
das von vielen kritisiert worden aber
dass wir noch einmal zwei wochen
verlängert haben da ist die hotspot
region gekommen ist dass die bevölkerung
damit auch den eindruck bekommen hat es
ist noch kein frieden jetzt kommt kein
frieden der sr stehen er findet nicht
statt das hat noch einmal ein signal an
die bevölkerung gegeben vorsichtiger zu
sein ich glaube es hat auch eine rolle
gespielt dass dann die fallzahlen
rückläufig geworden sind somit ich bin
persönlich mir bewusst dass also ich
viele punkte die ich durch jetzt zum
beispiel möchte aber dafür hätte ich
ehrlich gesagt bezahlt und das also ist
meine aufgabe und ich glaube dass wir
auch nach dieser also niederlage im
rahmen der allgemeinen im pflicht dass
wir für den herbst also gute
schutzregeln beschließen werden wir
werden gut auf die dann vor also vorher
schon den varianten uns vorbereiten wir
werden also das infektionsschutzgesetz
noch einmal überarbeitet werden
bevölkerung informieren wir werden kann
sicher auch bei der kampagne für die
fährte impfung noch etwas tun da rechne
ich auch noch einmal mit einer
überarbeitung der empfehlung und
durchsichtig oder ich habe die stiko
darum gebeten die also für die
vorschläge zu fördern oder noch einmal
zu überarbeiten ba rechnet in kürze mit
ergebnissen das heißt es geht immer
weiter wir haben bisher den schutz
anbieten können und werden das auch
weiter tun und also politik ist das
finden von kompromissen und da helfen
weder schuldzuweisungen noch also nach
karte rein wir werden da weiterkommen
russlands gibt von zdf fragt an sie herr
marx sie haben gerade berichtet dass die
krankenhäuser nicht zu sehr belastet
sind wegen der kogit patienten sondern
das problem das krankenhauspersonal ist
das infiziert und erkrankte ceo
inwiefern würde dann eine impfpflicht
helfen denn das krankenhauspersonal ist
ja geimpft
es ist völlig klar dass eine impfpflicht
für den akut für die aktuelle situation
überhaupt keine auswirkungen gehabt
hätte das war aber auch nie das thema
sondern es ging immer darum den nächsten
herbst im nächsten winter möglichst eben
nicht so wie die vergangenen zwei winter
zu erleben sondern dass wir wenn wir
überhaupt eine welle haben diese
deutlich flacher ist und die belastung
und drohende überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zu vermeiden
wissen die leute was sie haben jetzt
eben gesagt eigentlich keine oder kaum
chancen für neuen anlauf haben die
medien die gestern abend und auch heute
noch in printversion
mit der überschrift sie zitieren
lauterbach und wolle check für neuen
anlauf im herbst haben die das erfunden
haben die sie missverstanden oder hat
sich nicht doch ihre position nach dem
kategorischen nein des kanzlers heute
verändert
dann also die ich habe gestern ja auch
schon selbst in meiner rede darauf
hingewiesen dass gestern der tag war wo
wir zusammen kommen wir haben wir über
monate hinweg verhandelt
und wenn hier vorgetragen wird sollen
gespräche stattfinden und dann können
wir uns dem nicht verschließen aber also
man muss ja auch zu einer einschätzung
der lage kommen und die einschätzung der
lage ist für mich die solche gespräche
also darf man nicht ablehnen aber die
überschauen ich habe ich spreche jetzt
zu der wahrscheinlichkeit
dass bei solchen gesprächen etwas herum
kommt die betrachte ich als sehr gering
wir haben mich gestern also dazu
geäußert sollten gespräche geführt
werden das ist nicht falsch
verstanden worden ich nehme jetzt
stellung zu der frage wie wahrscheinlich
ist es denn dass wir da ein ergebnis
bekommen und bei der klarheit
also der niederlage im deutschen
bundestag fehlt mir die fantasie wie
sich das verändern sollte nachfrage sie
sind ja gestern ich sag's mal
ausgehebelt worden durch etwas also auf
bundesebene eigentlich seit acht jahren
nicht mehr gibt nämlich eine faktische
schwarz gelbe koalition mit anderen bei
farben
welche situationen sind vorstellbar dass
er noch ein erneuter anlauf für eine wie
auch immer gestaltete impfpflicht
chancen hätte also was muss passieren
damit diese negative prognose sagt
vielleicht müssen wir jetzt doch noch
mal dran ich bereite mich jetzt darauf
vor dass wir also im herbst keine
allgemeine impfpflicht haben werden das
muss man so klar hat und offen sagen die
mehrheitsverhältnisse im bundestag und
der bundestag müssen das ja also
beschließen sind so dass also eine
impfpflicht die wirklich funktionieren
würde da nicht erwartet werden kann das
heißt also gespräche sind immer schön
und gut und auch absichtsbekundungen
aber de facto gehe ich jetzt davon aus
dass wir mit anderen mitteln die
bevölkerung also schützen müssen dazu
zählen impfkampagne das so zählt eine
überarbeitung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes für den herbst
und dazu zählt auch also dass wir
uns gut vorbereiten wenn andere
varianten kommen so dass wir also für
unterschiedliche varianten auch
entsprechend impfen können diejenigen
die im fällig sind
dann erlebte
lauter war in dieser woche wurden
mehrere fälle bekannt aus
nordrhein-westfalen dass schulen
kommerzielle test stellen betreiber auf
dem schulgelände ihrer test errichten
lassen und die schüler sozusagen dort
als bürger test getestet werden es ist
ja nach der bundes spd sich weil das
eigentlich aufgabe des landes ist wie
bewerten sie diese fälle und können sie
abschätzen wie hoch der schaden für den
bund dadurch ist
ja in der tat dass die berichterstattung
darüber habe ich also gelesen und bin
auch also
in vorbereitung von gesprächen das muss
auf landesebene gesprochen werden ich
weise darauf hin die aufsicht darüber
haben die länder werden dass tatsächlich
mehr als einzelfälle wären dann wäre das
also sehr wichtig weil das würde quasi
das vertrauen in die seriosität der
testzentren und der test strategie
insgesamt natürlich bestätigen von da
sind das wichtige vorgänge sehr wichtige
vorgänge die sorgfältig geprüft werden
müssen ich bitte aber um verständnis
dass diese prüfung von seiten des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums noch nicht
abgeschlossen ist weil also wie dem
präzise nachgehen müssen und das über
die betroffenen länder aufholen eine
nachfrage weil der bundesrat geschädigte
werden sie da anzeige erstatten oder was
heißt prüfung konkret also wie spiegelt
das jetzt ab das ist noch in
vorbereitung also in der tat der
bundeswehr geschädigt so weit wir das
bezahlen die aufsicht über diese zentren
haben die kommunen und die länder somit
also muss hier eine gemeinsame lösung
gefunden werden
heinrich pette ja sebastian keine
kundendaten proportionen herr lauterbach
sind ja für millionen menschen und
gerade junge menschen so als
hoffnungsträger ins amt kommen
derartigen eindruck sein doch eine
social media kampagne in dieses amt auch
mit befördert worden jetzt ist gerade in
den letzten wochen sehr viel
enttäuschung auf denselben kanälen laut
geworden über über ihre performance und
gerade auf und auch der fehler die wir
selbst zugegeben haben und jetzt auch
noch gestern nach dem scheitern pflicht
trauen sie sich zu dieses vertrauen das
sie verloren haben wieder
zurückzugewinnen und wenn ja wie
vielen dank zu langsam obwohl ich die
sozialen medien sehr schätze wie bekannt
ist also ich bin kein influenza ich bin
politiker und daher muss ich die regeln
machen die funktionieren im rahmen
dessen was also politisch möglich ist
und da hole ich das maximum das maximum
für die bevölkerung heraus ich glaube
dass also spüren die menschen nach wie
vor da bekomme ich viel zustimmung nicht
nur die sozialen medien sondern auch im
persönlichen gespräch und auch in
umfragen also ich bin nicht dass also
unbeliebteste parlaments
kabinettsmitglied alles soweit gut also
mir geht es nicht darum also jetzt
bestimmten gruppen oder also wem auch
immer zu gefallen sondern die regeln
müssen funktionieren und beim
infektionsschutzgesetz zum beispiel habe
ich wirklich gekämpft dafür das maximum
was zu erreichen war herausholen da
hätten sich viele zum beispiel gewünscht
dass die masken pflicht fortgesetzt
worden wer aber marx hat es ja eben
gesagt deutschlandweit ist die
versorgung nicht so gefährdet also und
droht mich gefährdet zu sein daher war
da keiner stiche grundlage ich werde
immer wieder gesagt also hätte ich mich
hier durchsetzen müssen selbst wenn ich
das gesetz selbst gemacht hätte allein
ohne den kollegen buschmann
beispielsweise wäre das gleiche raus
gekommen dann hätte ich zwar die masken
pflicht vor geschehe vorgeschlagen sie
wäre aber dann in der ressortabstimmung
nicht weitergeführt worden weil die
rechtliche grundlage nicht da war und
das sind dinge die auch sofort kann man
nicht im netz erklären aber die kann man
hier in der bundespressekonferenz
erklären und da also hoffe ich auch auf
eine faire berichterstattung aber ich
bin im großen und ganzen also
diesbezüglich mit mir selbst im reinen
da sich wirklich versuche eine krone
politik zu machen die so viele menschen
schützt wie möglich dazu zählt die frühe
poster kampagne die weiterführung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes so lange wie es
gegen klare aufklärung dass wir also
tatsächlich nicht entfernen können einen
fehlen den nichts zuzulassen
impfstoffe zu beschaffen also die also
selbst die debatte um die impfpflicht
die nicht erfolgreich war aber selbst
die debatte war wertvoll weil eine
solche debatte in der bevölkerung auch
also den menschen klar macht wie wichtig
jetzt die eigenverantwortung ist man
muss daher selbst die debatten ehrlich
führen die der bevölkerung helfen die
lage richtig einzuschätzen
die zum schluss nicht das gewünschte
ergebnis bringen
bitte sehen sie aus ihrer sicht den
dienen die notwendigkeit was konkret zu
tun um das vertrauen zurückzugewinnen
sie haben ja eben auch den wenigen
fehler konkret zugegeben und und dort ja
offensichtlich in die defizite kann
glauben sie das persönlich was tun
müssen um da eben vertrauen
zurückzugewinnen ich glaube ich gesagt
dass ich das vertrauen also der breite
der bevölkerung nicht verloren habe und
will daher auch gar nicht auf die frage
eingehen was ich also machen muss um es
zu rücken wenn die maßen leute mit denen
ich spreche sind zufrieden damit dass
ich das beste versuche herauszuholen was
möglich ist und wenn ich beispielsweise
einen fehler korrigiert zum beispiel bei
der isolierung von menschen die verziert
sind wir das nicht mehr angeordnet werde
soll was ja also ein vorschlag gewesen
ist den ich gemacht hatte um die
gesundheitsämter zu entlassen wenn ich
das dann aber gut erklären und
zurücknehme dann wird das meine
glaubwürdigkeit nicht schwächen sondern
eher stärken dass es zumindest die
rückmeldung die ich bekomme ich glaube
dass viele leute sich wohler fühlen mit
einem minister der bereit ist einen
fehler einzuräumen um damit etwas zu
erreichen was die bevölkerung besser
schützt als das gefühl haben hier bleibt
ein minister bei einer position wo er
war es dass sie falsch ist und sieht das
einfach durch um sich nicht korrigieren
zu müssen glaubwürdigkeit ist für die
arbeit die ich mache immer ein hohes gut
das war am anfang so und das wird auch
weiter zu bleiben
rasmus buchsteiner von der panne fragt
sie professor wiler warum haben sie den
ursprünglichen plan von einem lauterbach
zur freiwilligen isolierung unterstützt
oder ist das eine fehlinformation
ja das robert koch institut berät ja
kontinuierlich das
bundesgesundheitsministerium und dieser
vorschlag wurde entsprechend gemeinsam
bearbeitet
dann die nächste fall herr kollege
wie hauptstadtstudio ich würde noch mal
die zahl der täglichen toten
interessieren
zwei bis dreihundert haben wir jetzt in
den letzten wochen gehabt können sie das
mal einordnen auch
wie lange erwartet uns das noch also
wird das jetzt dann irgendwann weniger
oder gehen sie davon aus dass das noch
länger so weitergehen wird und
sagen wir so otto normalverbraucher wenn
da draußen
schafft es nicht wirklich also das mag
sie schaffen das mag mich schocken aber
so richtig kommen die zahlen da draußen
aus meiner sicht zumindest nicht an
was heißt das denn wenn man das in
relation setzt also ist das sind das
zahlen die mit mit einer handelsüblichen
grippewelle vergleichbar sind pro tag
oder ist dass deutlich mehr können sie
das mal in relation bringen was das
letztlich jetzt heißt ich würde gerne
die frage von gisela breuer dazu die
geht jetzt an professor wieder war
vielleicht kann sich jetzt auf sein wie
hoch ist derzeit die letalität rate von
coop 19 in deutschland welche die
identitätsdaten gab es bei influenza in
den letzten jahren vor der pandemie
fange ich vielleicht andere sowie 200
bis 300 toten wie lange geht das noch
also wir werden das auf jeden fall noch
ein paar wochen wahrscheinlich sehen
weil die menschen versterben jahr
weniger also wochen nach der infektion
das haus wir haben jetzt die gute
nachricht die fahrzeugen gehen deutlich
herunter die schlechte nachricht es sind
natürlich noch viele infizierte die in
den nächsten wochen versterben werden
und das ist schon eine deutliche über
sterblichkeit also das hat mit einer
normalen grippe werde natürlich nichts
zu tun das ist klar wenn sie das jetzt
also über die vielen
wochen beziehen wo wir dass
wir das jetzt erleben
dann ist das also schon
eine das ist ein drittel von der
höchstzahl der sterbe der todesfälle je
gehabt haben in der größenordnung ist
das und das ist eine höhere also
sterblichkeit als wir in der ersten
welle gehabt haben als wir kamen die
wohnungen verlassen haben also zu dem
zeitpunkt wo noch niemand geimpft waren
wir haben kaum die wohnung verlassen
hatten wir eine sterblichkeit in dieser
größenordnung und wir gehen mit dieser
sterblichkeit jetzt ganz anders um aber
richtig ist das nicht und für mich so
was nicht maßgeblich wie reagiert die
bevölkerung darauf sondern für mich ist
maßgeblich das müssen wir stoppen und es
darf vor allen dingen im herbst nicht
erneut passieren werden wir im herbst an
ihnen also in den dritten herbst in
ahlen gehen und haben dann erneut 200
300 tote pro tag und dann über eine so
lange strecke
das kann nicht akzeptiert werden das ist
nicht richtig und von daher werden wir
alles tun um das zu verhindern
auch dann wenn die impfpflicht nicht
durchsetzbar ist
darauf hinweisen marx hat das eben schon
ausgeführt und wenn man auf die
intensivstation in jetzt geht also viele
sterben die gar nicht auf die
intensivstation kommen muss man auch
sagen aber die wenn man auf die
intensivstation kommt dann sieht man
dort auf zwei gruppen nämlich älterer
die ungeimpft sind und dann ältere die
zeugen sind aber komorbiditäten haben
die quasi also die impfung nicht
kompensieren konnten das sieht man in
frankreich so dass irgendwo bei uns das
sind leute die haben alles getan um sich
zu schützen weil die wissen ja dass in
die karten haben meinetwegen jemand
darin lymphom hat ein klassisches
beispiel am markt wird das bestätigen
können jemand ein infoblatt den kann ich
mit der nicht bei allen impfungen und so
aber vielen den kann ich mit den
impfungen nicht gut schützen diese leute
haben jetzt zweieinhalb jahre fast haben
die also sich versucht zu schützen und
infizieren sich jetzt weil die fahrzeuge
und so sind und wissen dass die impfung
sie nicht von schwerer krankheit
schützen kann und verstärken das ist ein
umstand den ich nicht
akzeptieren kann und das müssen wir im
herbst verhindern jetzt können wir das
kaum mehr verhindern herr marx hat es
ganz genau beschrieben die impfpflicht
hat darauf keine konsequent alkan
einfluss mehr aber für den herbst müssen
wir das verhindern
ich kann das gern noch ergänzen also wir
haben wir werden wir gehen davon aus hat
er gesagt wir wissen dass die menschen
die sie infizieren diejenigen die
versterben versterben in der regel zwei
bis drei wochen später das heißt also
damit kann man ja relativ klar voraus
sehen jetzt wo die welle quasi den
scheitelpunkt erreicht hat momentan das
dass das eben noch zwei drei wochen
später wir eben dann die opfer beklagen
werden ich möchte aber noch etwas
anderes sagen was mir wichtig ist
also wenn sie mal die ganze pandemie
betrachten und wir sind jetzt quasi im
zwei jahre vier monate etwa in dieser
pandemie wenn sie die zahlen betrachten
und die todeszahlen betrachten wenn wir
auf die zahlen schauen wir hatten ja
jetzt erst nach zwei jahren also wenn
wir ein sommer den januar anfang januar
etwa vor vier monaten da hatten wir und
in deutschland rund siebeneinhalb
millionen fälle wir haben jetzt rund 24
25 millionen fälle das heißt also wenn
mit zwei jahren 7 millionen fälle wurde
dem rk ii gemeldet und den dreieinhalb
in drei vier monaten wurden dem rk ii
doppelt so viele fälle gemeldet wir
haben also quasi zwei drittel aller
fälle in diesem jahr gehabt schauen sie
aber auf die zahlen die toten die uns
gemeldet wurden dem rk ii dann hatten
wir anfangen januar glaube ich ungefähr
113000 in dieser größenordnung also es
sind alles schreckliche zahlen aber ich
sage einfach mal 113.000 und heute aber
glaube ich
132000 das heißt also in diesen vier
monaten hatten wir doppelt so viele
infektionen aber wir haben nur ein
siebtel etwa der todeszahlen warum ist
das so das hat zwei entscheidende gründe
erstens gott sei dank gibt es viele
menschen die klug genug sind und wissen
dass die impfung schützt wir haben ja
einen impfstoff wir haben immerhin 75 76
prozent der bevölkerung komplett mit
einer grundimmunisierung versorgt das
ist der eine grund warum eben nicht mehr
so viele versterben obwohl wir sowohl
zahlen haben und der zweite grund das
ist aber reines glück der zweite grund
ist nämlich der dass diese variante auch
nicht mehr so viel schwerer verläufe
macht wie die vorherige variante so aber
jetzt geschieht ja folgendes und das ist
ja der punkt warum wir immer wieder
darauf hinweisen dass die partie nicht
vorbei ist und das ist im herbst wieder
anders wird jeder der sich inhaltlich
wirklich sachlich damit beschäftigt weiß
dass im erb winter die zahlen wieder
steigen werden aber natürlich kann
niemand vorhersagen wie hoch sie steigen
aber was wir wissen ist dass die
immunität nachlässt das heißt heute hat
jemand der jetzt hier sitzt ich zum
beispiel wenn ich mich nicht noch mal
impfen lasse habe im herbst eine
geringere immunität als ich es heute
habe das heißt dass darum muss ich die
auffrischung der zweite aspekt ist ja
wir wissen nicht und kein mensch auf der
welt weiß welche variante denn kommt
beten wir dass es eine omikron variante
bleibt weil die eben relativ milde ist
aber es kann auch eine variante sein die
eben wieder deutlich mehr krankheit
macht und darum ist der entscheidende
punkt ja jetzt im sommer natürlich wir
müssen uns auch erholen ich meine wir
alle auch eine erholung ja wir müssen
uns erholen also gerade die erz und
ärzten und aber so viele menschen am
land die jetzt wirklich zwei jahre lang
vieles durchgemacht haben aber im herbst
wird es eben wieder ansteigen und ich
kann es nicht verstehen warum man sich
dann nicht wirklich nach all den fakten
der weltweit publiziert sind milliarden
menschen gehen daten sind alle da warum
man dann sich nicht eben impfen lässt
umsicht um dem zu entgehen ja und das
heißt also betrachten sie das das ist
der erfolg der impfung warum jetzt nur
so relativ wenig menschen in dem
zeitraum verstorben sind aber eben die
impfung schützt eben nicht so stark vor
der infektion und das muss man wirklich
immer klar war halten und auch ein
letzter satz vielleicht noch mal
darum es gibt immer noch nicht wenn man
antikörper hat gegen dieses virus dann
heißt das eben nicht unbedingt dass man
geschützt ist das heißt also wenn man
virus kontakt hatte heißt das noch lange
nicht dass man eine immunität an das bti
auch immer wieder darüber nachzudenken
wir haben sehr viele menschen unserem
land jetzt nach diesen wahnsinnigen
infektionszahlen die ein antikörper
status haben das heißt aber nicht dass
sie eine gute bonität
ganz gut ergänzen darf diese frage mit
erkrankungen und
infiziert wird jetzt mit oracle oder
eine andere variante des virus der punkt
ist wenn man eine eine erkrankung hat
und diese durch die infektion so
verstärkt wird dass der patient am ende
stört dann stirbt er am ende nicht an
der grunderkrankung sondern an der
infektion ich glaube das ist nochmal
ganz wichtig und das zeigen auch
theologische studien dass wirklich die
allermeisten patienten möglich ancona
verstorben sind an der infektion
ich habe noch eine frage die das
christkind sondern faz fragt auch einmal
an sie professor marx schützt das impfen
wirklich verschwören verläufen wie viele
intensivpatienten sind folge impft
wieviel intensivpatienten sind folge
impft sie erfassen das ja und im moment
sehen wir dass etwa die hälfte aller
intensivpatienten ungeimpft sind und
viele der geimpften haben eben eine wie
wir selber sagen co mobilität also eine
vorerkrankung und deswegen wirkt oft die
impfung nicht so gut als eine
entsprechende ausreichende immunität
vorhanden ist um eben vor den schweren
verläufen zu schützen
da habe ich
jungen
leute passiert man gesagt dass spielraum
für lockerungen ist komplett
aufgebraucht was heißt das genau
also dass es gar keine lockerungs
möglichkeiten mehr gibt und was ist
eigentlich noch der unterschied zu einer
lese fair corona politik
ja ich bin ein beispiel wenn wir bei
jetzt davon abstand nehmen würden das
also quarantäne und isolation überhaupt
notwendig sind das haben wir einige
europäische länder gemacht dann wäre das
eine sehr wichtige lockerung also
bedeuten dass also dann kohler behandelt
wurde wie eine erkältungskrankheit
und also diese lockerung ist ja auch
also
vorgeschlagen worden an mich
herangetragen worden das werden wir
nicht machen und wir haben nach wie vor
auch also schutz
bedingungen im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr
wir haben also schutz bedingungen die
stattfinden
in den einer in den einrichtungen
gerufene radler gruppen also betraut
werden also von der eingliederungshilfe
über krankenhaus der pflege und wir
haben natürlich die hotspot regelungen
die jederzeit genutzt werden kann wenn
wir wieder ausbrüche haben die lokal
begrenzt sind somit also denke ich
einmal haben wir schon noch ein
instrumentarium also was genutzt werden
kann stellen wir uns folgendes vor wir
werden ja im sommer nicht komplett
infektions frei sein wenn sich dann
beispielsweise in einer stadt also ein
hotspot ergeben würde wohl auch sehr
viele menschen infiziert sind und über
gesundheitsgefährdungen in dieser stadt
konstatiert wurde wir sind ja in vielen
städten ausmalen was ich damals im
moment an diesem punkt schon phasen
aus meiner sicht könnte die hotspot
regelung ja viel mehr genutzt werden als
die derzeit produziert dann haben wir
aber diese instrumente am platz und die
werden auch nicht aufgehoben
eine grundsätzliche frage aber das war
jetzt schon das thema hier warum ist
eigentlich ein koalitionsfrieden
wichtiger als der schutz der bevölkerung
ein lotto der koalitionsfrieden steht
nicht dem schutz der bevölkerung
entgegen das ist einfach so dass wir in
der koalition uns auf dem kompromiss
leben also
regeln verständigen die regeln haben uns
bisher ganz gut geschützt wurde ich mal
sagen das wird auch weiter so sagen dass
dann kein rezept fragt noch an sie beide
erläutert bacher wähler zum omikron
impfstoff wieso kommt er später bringt
ihr noch etwas an wie weit es moderner
mit einem polyvalenten impfstoff
ich bin mit den beiden unternehmen den
engen austausch und in der tat dauert
die entwicklung etwas länger als
ursprünglich also erwartet war das ist
die also ungünstige nachricht die
günstige nachricht ist aber dass die
bisherigen
forschungsergebnisse die mir bekannt
sind sehr vielversprechend sind so dass
wir im herbst an solchen impfstoff haben
werden es zeichnet sich auch ab dass ein
solcher impfstoff
für diejenigen die also bereits mit
einem anderen impfstoff geimpft sind
oder gleichzeitig mit einem oralen
impfstoff geimpft werden eine gute
schutzwirkung
sowie auch für andere varianten bieten
könnte darauf weisen die also bisher
bekannten forschungsergebnisse hin und
das wird umgesetzt indem moderner einen
bivalenten impfstoff wahrscheinlich
bringen wird der aus einem comic con im
stoff und einem hahn impfstoff besteht
und also vom montag wahrscheinlich
anrainer nikon impfstoff bringen wird
der dann insbesondere für diejenigen
interessant ist die ich schon einmal
also mit einer anderen variante
infiziert waren oder an uran impfstoff
schon gehabt haben das ist ungefähr das
was wir da warten wir also fahren wir
zweigleisig das heißt wir also an uns
entsprechend ausreichende kontingente
also von uran im stoff bereits gesichert
und haben wir auch wenn der harn
impfstoff benötigt wird und wir haben
auch vertraglich also bisher also einen
also omikron impfstoff in ausreichender
menge bereits gesichert und
planen also die absicherung auch eines
weiteren also omikron spezifischen
impfstoffe so dass wir im herbst auf
jeden fall
impfen quellen und herr marx hat es
gesagt nach ávila das gesamte
gage punkt also wir müssen damit rechnen
dass die jetzt geimpften im herbst nicht
mehr so gut geschützt sein spätestens
dann also sind für viele neue impfungen
notwendig und darf dafür sind wir
vorbereitet
ich habe doch zwei online fragen eine
ist von
nochmals und zwar zum thema impfpflicht
aber die einrichtungs bezogene und zwar
an sie herr lauterbach sehen sie einen
zusammenhang zwischen dem scheitern der
impfpflicht gestern und der einrichtungs
bezogen nämlich droht der einrichtungs
bezogenen impfpflicht jetzt das aus vor
gericht nein das aus fordere ich dort
meines erachtens nicht wir lassen alles
was wir machen rechtlich prüfen das ist
ja klar und sind auch bisher mit den
maßen unserer maßnahmen recht
erfolgreich gewesen somit also glaube
ich dass wir auch hier gelten die
einrichtungs bezogen pflicht ist sehr
präzise formulierte geht es um den
schutz der wohlhabenden gruppen und
leistungsbezogene impfpflicht ist auch
bisher ganz gut angenommen worden und
hilf uns über ins jahr ich habe mir
haben ihren gesprochen 200 bis 300 tote
pro tag die zahl der todesfälle ist in
den letzten
wochen sogar etwas gestiegen das kann
uns nicht befriedigen aber wir haben
tatsächlich die situation verhindern
können dass ein großer teil dieser
staffel aus dem aus den
pflegeeinrichtungen zum beispiel kommt
der schutz in die pflegeeinrichtung ist
uns gelungen nicht perfekt aber dort
lägen noch hoch von gruppen und das ist
glaube ich die erste welle wo wir also
die menschen die in pflegeeinrichtungen
versorgt werden
deutlich besser schützen so dass wir
dort keine überproportionale und
unvertretbare sterbe zu kurze hätten
julia frisch von der ärzte zeitung fragt
nach dem thema corona bonus minister
lauterbach hatte im januar ein
bonussystem für arztpraxen angekündigt
was ist daraus geworden und wie soll es
aussehen
ja wir haben uns also bisher beim cola
bonus konzentriert auf die
[Musik]
auf die langzeit und altenpflege und auf
die krankenpflege haben dort auch einen
entsprechenden
gesetzentwurf
gestern in der ersten lesung präsentiert
und zum jetzigen zeitpunkt ist noch kein
pflege bonus oder kann also bonus für
die arztpraxen geplant das hat auch
damit zu tun dass wir also
dass wir also uns auf die gruppen zuerst
konzentrieren hier besonders also im
also in die hier besonders gefordert
gewesen sind und das sind die
pflegekräfte und dann habe ich auch eine
letzte frage zum thema
sie habe ich mal sehen dann die
vorletzte frage sebastian huld von n-tv
fragt sie ich zitiere jetzt die frage
sie drohen mit einer rückkehr mit der
masten pflicht im herbst weil die
impfpflicht gescheitert ist wird die
masten pflicht bei der nächsten welle
zur vermeidung hoher krankenstände nicht
unabhängig von einer impfquote nötig
seien also zunächst einmal wo ich nicht
sondern ich habe nur darauf hingewiesen
ich habe ja die allgemeine impfpflicht
mit der also befürchtung begründet dass
wir im herbst vor einer weiteren welle
stehen und das glaube ich sehen auch
wieder thema zu und wenn dem so ist
müssen wir es anders solchen also wähle
auch begegnen können und also eine
winter welle oder herbst und winter
welle die können wir dass es dann
natürlich zu besprechen aber die können
wir auf der grundlage der einschätzungen
die mir jetzt vorliegen und so ich auch
den expertenrat mit dem ich mich
regelmäßig also austausche noch meine
eigenen lesart der epidemiologischen
also fakten können wir nicht bewältigen
ohne das waren das
infektionsschutzgesetz noch einmal heran
gehen das ist ja auch am 23.9
ausgelaufen dann müssen wir ohnedies ich
glaube dass wir dann auch zu einer maske
pflicht zuge kommen werden und als
letztes vergessen nochmal zwar kurze
fragen einer lauterbach ein händler herr
lauterbach die korona waren beliefert
täglich viele upgedatet daten eine aber
nicht die zahl der täglichen todeszelle
gehört die nicht eigentlich auch damit
rein um einfach die letzte konsequenz
deutlich zu machen und herr villa
22 millionen bekannte infektionen von
welcher dunkelziffer gehen sie aus
in der tat ist es so dass wir über die
todesfälle pro tag also je berichten
dass moderator institut macht das jeden
tag die zahl wird auch in den
nachrichtensendungen
regelmäßig also vorgetragen dass sie in
der app nicht erscheint das
muss noch einmal überdacht werden ob das
vielleicht sinnvoll wäre aber ich glaube
das problem ist nicht dass also
diejenigen die die app benutzen dort
nicht die zahl der verstorbenen sehen
sondern ich glaube das ist in der
bevölkerung leide eine gewisse
abstumpfung gibt und dass wir uns
zunehmend an diese zahl der toten
gewöhnt haben und das finde ich
schwierig und
also das ist etwas was ich also
persönlich nicht akzeptieren kann und
also was auf jeden fall nicht
stattfinden wird was man an der krone
politik macht die also sagt danach geht
voran hat sich die bevölkerung gewöhnt
sondern wir müssen die bevölkerung
schützen und da ist also das was
tatsächlich stattfindet relevant und
nicht die einschätzung
ja das ist eine sehr gut und auch
wichtige frage um das einschätzen zu
können muss man serologische studien
durchführen da werden eine reihe von
studien durchgeführt in deutschland wir
haben ja auf der webseite des robert
koch instituts waren observatorium zur
verfügung gestellt wo jeder der
interesse hat reinschauen kann was denn
an daten da ist also
wir haben gesehen und wie die letzten
zwei jahre dass die untererfassung immer
so ungefähr um faktor 2 ist das hieße
also wir gehen von mindestens mal
doppelt so vielen infektionen aus als
die in dem überwachungssystem gesehen
weil das ist eigentlich ziemlich normal
auch für alle mögliches thema jetzt will
ich kurz drei studien nennen die die wir
in kürze auch publizieren werden und die
dann noch mal das nochmal glaube ich
noch mal sehr gut klar stellen denn
natürlich war die letzte wendet diese
mikrowelle war ja so hoch dass dort man
eher davon ausgeht dass die unter
erfassen da noch höher ist weil das
wirklich einfach nicht mehr zu händen
ist es gibt drei studien wir machen eine
studie die haben wir seit glaube ich
mitte 2020 gemacht wo wir blutspender
serien nehmen da haben wir bisher glaube
so und 115000 oder so etwa untersucht
und da hatten wir im
herbst ich glaube im september 20 21
eine eine eine rate von positiven
antikörper für etwa 87 prozent
man muss man sagen davon waren etwa 82
prozent durch impfungen hervorruft bei
diesen bei diesen menschen die blut
spenden blutspender sind menschen die
sind nicht repräsentativ für unser land
das sind alles sehr gesunde leute und es
sind auch menschen die
gesundheitsbewusst leben das heißt da
ist die impfrate besonders hoch da
machen wir eine studie wenn ich das
richtig im kopf habe wir werden jetzt im
april noch mal etwa 15.000 zehren von
den testen dann kriegen wir so im juni
haben wir dann die daten mai juni wie
viel da sind daran können wir das
abschätzen die wichtigste studie ist die
die haben wir schon im letzten jahr
gemacht zusammen mit dem
sozioökonomischen panel da hatten wir
ende 2020 gezeigt dass in deutschland
nur rund zwei prozent der bevölkerung
nur zwei prozent der bevölkerung
antikörper hatten das heißt wir haben
echt extrem erfolgreich konnte im ersten
jahr in deutschland und diese studie
läuft jetzt gerade wir haben die letzten
serien ende februar diesen jahres
genommen aber die studie ist sehr
komplex weil wir so viele wirklich sehr
repräsentativ auch bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen da muss man viele
nachrichten da gehe ich davon aus dass
die daten erst im mai juni wirklich
fertig sein werden und dann gibt es eine
dritte studie die ist aber jetzt nicht
die berühmte jetzt gar nicht so sehr auf
realen proben sondern ist eine
modellierung wir wollen mit unserer
modellierungs team im rk ii machen da
habe ich glaube schon vor zwei oder vier
wochen schon mal gesagt dass ich davon
ausgehe dass die haben im april wirkte
wurde publiziert da modulieren war
anhand der daten und zwar bis wir
modulieren anhand der daten die uns bis
ende märz vorlage also sehr sehr aktuell
wie viele menschen wir wohl denken in
deutschland antigen kontakt hatten und
da geht muss man natürlich davon
ausgehen dass über 90 prozent sind ja
dann ist noch die frage woher kommen
diese antikörper durch natürliche
infektion oder durch durch infektion
aber ich will eben noch mal sagen dass
also antigen kontakt haben sehr viele
menschen natürlich in unserem land
gehabt aber ich möchte noch mal wirklich
betont man darf nicht den fehler machen
und sagen wenn ein mensch antikörper hat
das er dann geschützt ist wir haben
gerade erst letzte woche wieder in einem
intensiven austausch auch mit wäre und
bestimmten gremien es gibt immer noch
keinen täter immer noch kein twitter wo
man sagt wenn einer sein die körper tüte
hat dann ist der geschützt das gibt ist
immer noch nicht da und wir müssen das
einfach so hinnehmen wir können leider
noch nicht im labor haben wir noch immer
noch keinen zugang zu sagen diese oder
jene person hat diese und jene parameter
darum ist sie immun geschützt dann sind
wir am ende ich bin haben mich ganz
herzlich für die aufmerksamkeit und die
geduld und für die es kommen in die
bundespressekonferenz